my name is dennis cowan i'm a comic book
artist and one of the founders of
milestone media with the relaunch of
milestone media we're collaborating with
ally to continue to provide opportunity
for the next generation of diverse
creators
we created milestone media as a response
to the lack of black representation in
the comic book world in the 90s
when i came into the industry there
weren't many black complex artists
that's what we're thinking about who's
going to carry that legacy forward
[Music]
this past year theon and kareem founded
the first ever pro-black pop culture
collectible store in carson california
black star collectibles
[Music]
how did you guys first
hear about milestone how old were you
guys i was 18 i think he was
17 17. i was going to my regular comic
book shop i saw for the very first time
a section
of just black superheroes
and the guys working are like what's
this oh this is a new comic company
called milestone um they're through dc
comics
so i immediately had to show my best
friend over here you took him to the
store yeah yeah came right back to the
store yeah he showed me and i was just
like focusing on the x-hat you know the
x-hat was just a significant
symbol
of pride
and so seeing a comic book character
with the exhale i was like what why you
got the exercise oh he's like oh yeah
you didn't know and this is not and he
says what
dakota was compton we were static shock
icon looks like my dad oh my just strong
powerful figure all that stuff means
something all that stuff's important the
fact that you guys saw yourselves
in the x-cap that gave you an image that
gave you something
and that led you to where you are now
whether i'm going to do a superhero
comic book myself or i'm going to open a
store
i can see myself in that space now it
just blew my mind that was it it was
like my life was complete that's what
lit the fire
i think in us
it lit the fire that was really the goal
telling the truth
you know that as we saw it i think it
would be up to the fans to tell us if we
succeeded you succeeded best yeah
succeeded there you go
we want underrepresented people to work
with us in comics so with ally we've
teamed up to create the milestone
initiative at the end of the course
you'll be a comic book professional and
ready to go
it's just about passing it on just like
you guys are trying to do at black star
collectibles if it wasn't for milestone
i wouldn't have been inspired
in that section
in the comic store
of
your books of milestone books
it was one of the inspirations like we
should have a whole store like oh my god
so you saw a section in
from that created a store yeah what we
wanted to do was introduce those kids to
daddy shock
to
icon or rocket into just all the
characters that look like them and once
we did that we were just like
superheroes we would love you the
superhero because you were superheroes
yeah yeah today you know that's our goal
just to inspire we as we've been
inspired by individuals like yourself
and others the lightning in their
eyeballs and the smile on their face
when they come back again and they're
like i need book two yeah i need book
three i need the next issue where is it
at yeah i get butterflies every time i
walk in the store and we hope that we're
giving the same effect to others when
they come into the store that butterfly
effect
as much as milestone has been there for
us growing up we want black star
collectibles to be that way for our
community
what we're doing is carrying that
tradition on the milestone initiative is
part of that what you guys are doing
at blackstar collectibles is part of
that and it's all vitally important it's
all it's all needed when we started
milestone back in 92 we never imagined
it could be where it is today because it
had never been done before it's always
been about building allies about
creating opportunities knowing that
we're stronger together and together we
can persevere
[Music]
it's all about building your community
and having your eyes on those big
moments together
my team at milestone and ally have our
eyes on the future with this initiative
learn more about the milestone
initiative at dcuniverse.com
milestone thanks again to alive and our
friends at dc for powering this exciting
opportunity for milestone media comic
book artists and fans
you